[Music]
we're gonna read chat up lines in some
in english and some in spanish and we're
gonna try and
work out which is the
yeah i mean i mean i use it a lot when i
do you know
cpr
cbr no
well that's not the right art you have
to come back with why why i'm guessing
why because you take my breath away
so how would we rate that at one to ten
two
and eight
series
it's very important how you move your
mouth when you say okay so say it again
is um chocolate
kind of like chocolate
from which
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
a wi-fi hot spot
[Music]
why
because i feel a connection
that's so cheap it's so cheap cheap how
am i getting at ten
two i think you have to work in it work
work
do you know what would look great
[Music]
oh my god that's the most like
egocentric narcissistic thing
that's quite the opposite we did it
again do you know what would look great
on you don't change things
me
there's always about me
serum okay yours
i was looking for my
how do you call this half
orange
yeah
but you are my whole piece of fruit
just for the specificity thank you bye
bye bye
bye-bye mine is the winner the hospital
the one that i've been using like my
whole life did you have did it happen
yeah have you actually ever used that
like i promise
what was the response you got from that
kiss
okay if you want to see
how sam clathlin
fails to shout out people
on screen as well as on screen
go see our new movie book of love see us
in the book of love
[Music]
[Applause]
i made some changes
what have you done to my book
[Music]
you